There's so few Jedi left.
She's coming.
Our enemies are multiplying.
The galaxy is not safe.
I could use the help.
It's now or never.
Once a rebel.
Always a rebel.
Hunt them down.
This is where it gets interesting.
Get ready. Ready. Ready.
Oh, wow.
Always do.
There are no more, no less.
A master
and an apprentice.
Be mindful of the living
force, Young Padawan.
You will be tempted
by the dark side of the force
one must destroy in order to create
Master.
It's been a while.
Things have changed.
Sometimes we have to do what's right.
Confronting
fear is the destiny of a generation.
Buckle up.
Never be afraid
I'm what you have here.
We have what may grow beyond that.
Is that true? Burden of all matters.
So go to episode from the streaming
August 23rd on Disney Plus.
Welcome back everyone
There's a brand new Ahsoka
trailer there's a whole bunch of new footage,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
I'll be doing videos for all the episodes,
just like all the other Star Wars
Disney Plus series.
They start in a couple of weeks.
And I'll do a giveaway during the episode
videos, just like I normally do.
just starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage
and we're going to wade through
shot by shot, talking about Easter eggs,
WTF moments.
They also finally revealed something
about what's going on
with all these brand new characters
to probably one of the biggest
reveals in the trailer is like a blink
and you'll miss it
kind of moment
because you only see the back of his head.
But this looks like Kenan in here, his son
Jason from Star Wars
Rebels just a little bit older.
That's why he's so much shorter than Hera
sitting in the seat.
really important reminder
that he is for sensitive
and potentially another tree,
another Padawan for Ahsoka.
maybe, maybe we'll see.
Force goes Kanan
or some sort of flashback scene.
Or somehow
we'll see a live action version of Kanan.
There are a number of different ways
to accomplish that,
even if he's dead in present day.
The first new scene is a soldier
fighting the Sith Inquisitor Marrok.
While you get voiceover from Ray
Stevenson's Baylan Skoll character.
May he rest in peace.
when Ahsoka squares off with him getting
ready to actually start their fight.
We've seen versions of this scene
in the other trailers,
but this is a bunch of new footage
from that scene.
Baylan Skoll is talking to someone on comms,
it sounds like about how there's
so few Jedi left,
and I think that's meant
to be a reference to him
because he is a former Jedi
the whole idea with his character
is they confirmed
and he talked about Anakin Skywalker
in the previous trailers
is that he used to be a Jedi
but he's survived order 66
and since the fall of the Jedi
he's become a mercenary
and that's how he's been earning money.
So he's not meant to be a Sith
or anything like that. But.
According to Dave Filoni, that's
why his lightsaber has turned orange.
So it's not full sith red,
but obviously it's grown much darker.
So I think it's more appropriate
to call him a dark Jedi.
they might have a better term for that
during the series.
Like there's a whole idea of Gray
that I even though Dave Filoni says that
Ahsoka is not meant to be a great Jedi
when he's talking to his apprentice,
she's not here.
She has the same orange type
of lightsaber,
even though their hilts
are very different.
This is what their hilts
actually look like.
lot of people were asking
if she was actually using Kanan
Jarrus is lightsaber hilt here.
It's not his. It's
just meant to be similar to his hilt.
the whole idea with their characters,
with the Sophia's character, with Grogu.
Whose character is they're all choosing
their own path of the force, forging
this new path that's different
from the traditional Jedi Order way.
The old Jedi way
in the way they talked about
at least canonically
is that Luke Skywalker's Jedi Academy?
And one of the reasons why
eventually fell is that he was following
the traditional Jedi, always trying
to recreate the traditional Jedi order
This is a big change through the legends
canon.
In the legends
canon, things were a little bit different.
So I think that's
why some fans were disappointed
when they found out
what happened to Luke Skywalker.
Jedi Academy like why would it fall?
Why would he make the same mistakes
as the previous Jedi?
hopefully Dave Filoni
and Jon Favreau will recontextualize
that the way that they do
with a lot of things and make it seem way,
way cooler than the newer movies
did, there's kind of been Dave
Filoni thing in the past taking things
from the prequels
and recontextualizing them
with new episodes to make them seem way.
We're cooler in retrospect. must take
which is
also probably one of the reasons
why they are doing Mando verse movie
Instead in this part of the timeline,
at least according to the official news
release from Dave Filoni, the Star Wars
people, the Miracle Sith Inquisitor
character is a former inquisitor.
That's why they're wearing the inquisitor
armor using the Inquisitor light saber.
But Since the events of Return of the Jedi
in the fall of the Inquisitor Arias
they've also just become another mercenary
and have been working for Morgan Elsbeth
in her bid to try and bring Thrawn back
to the normal part of the galaxy.
so there are a bunch of different moments
in the trailer, different scenes of Ahsoka
fighting this Merak character.
And I know there are a lot of people
asking
there's a huge twist
because
why would they keep wearing the mask
if it wasn't meant to be
this big mystery surprise character like,
Oh my God, I never believed
it was this person under the mask.
maybe their name
Merak is something that they chose for
themselves when they became an inquisitor.
So even if it's not going to be Ezra
in surprise, like surprise, it's been me
this whole time.
I'm not expecting that as much now,
just because they've been working
for Morgan Elsbeth in the whole idea
that she's trying to bring Thrawn back to
the galaxy in, Ezra got lost, withdrawn.
So if Thrawn isn't completely back yet
at the very beginning of the series,
then Ezra
probably wouldn't be back as well.
kind of soft confirming
that the Merak character is not Ezra.
then there's another
totally different scene Baylan Skoll
on what looks like Thrawn's ship
and he's in a hollow talking to
what might be Thrawn maybe Morgan Elsbeth.
At this point it's
hard to say what point in the series
this scene is coming
from just warning them
that Ahsoka is coming for them,
this is what Theron's new ship looks like.
I think he has a couple of ships
like this.
I guess part of this mystery fleet
that he found in the unknown regions.
This meant to be similar
to some of the storyline from Dark Force
Rising during the original Thrawn trilogy.
But. It seems like Morgan Elsbeth sends
these H.K.
droids and Roarke after Ahsoka
to stop her from stopping them
from bringing Thrawn back.
then we get some voiceover from Ahsoka
talking to the being,
trying to win her over to her, like,
Come help me,
because we have all these enemies
that are popping up all over the place.
We have to deal with.
she's talking about Thrawn,
she's talking about Shin Hati and Baylan Skoll,
all these different characters
that are slowly massing against them.
Because even though Baylan Skoll
is working with Thrawn and Morgan Elsbeth,
technically they're not on the same side.
We get that same scene of them activating
what looks like the star map.
Like you need to be force
sensitive to use the star maps.
So that might be why Morgan Elsbeth starts
working with Balan school
Then we see a much longer scene of Ahsoka
finding Balan school
in the same area around the star map,
with it active.
Not totally sure what Sabine Wren
is doing during this scene,
but it seems like it's still on the trail.
She has a custom
speeder bike that she's repainted herself
in her own custom art style.
That's why her helmet looks different.
That's why her Mandalorian helmet
looks different to
Her hair is a little bit longer
during this scene.
So I'm assuming this is before Ahsoka
comes back to get her and they show you
the E wing.
A lot of people asking about the E wing
because it's like a legends thing
that they've slowly
brought back into the canon
a couple of times.
the E wing is a super deep cut.
It actually debuted during Star Wars
Dark Empire graphic novel,
which is one of my favorite
classic used Star Wars stories.
I remember seeing this in the nineties.
I just think it was the coolest thing ever
because that was during an era
when there were no Star Wars prequels, yet
we didn't know they were going to do
the prequels.
This came during the nineties
around the same time
the original Thrawn trilogy came.
So for people around that period,
they didn't know that
there would be prequels in more movies.
Eventually this stuff sort of
was like the sequel trilogy for us.
the other thing too is the R2 unit inside
the E wing is also based
on the original prototype
for the R2 toy way, way back in the day
Dave Filoni is known for doing stuff
like this, like pulling super
deep cuts out of the canon
to do stuff like this little Easter eggs.
We get that line from here again.
Once a rebel, always a rebel,
which is a Star Wars rebels reference
because they're doing all these Star Wars
rebels characters in live action
now, just like we saw Zeb
during The Mandalorian Season 3.
He'll probably be back during his
at some point to Baylan Skoll
ordering Marrok inquisitor
and his apprentice Shin Hati.
The other HK droids to go after Ahsoka
and everyone else.
Then they have a much longer fight
in that forested area, that same area
where he's telling them to go after him.
we get a brand new line
from David Tennant's Jedi
droid where he says
this is where it gets interesting.
Which reminds me of the Anakin
Skywalker line.
This is where the fun begins
as this thing is meant to be light
Easter eggs and things for
and it can showing up.
But obviously David Tenet's Jedi
Droid is a huge Easter egg
for the Clone Wars episodes.
I suggest you listen and learn
until you think of a question
this droid cannot answer.
We don't know a lot
about what was going on with his character
during this part of the timeline.
So it'll be interesting to see at
what point he started flying with Ahsoka.
when they had the montage
of all the different characters
saying that they're ready in completely
different scenes just cut together.
we finally get Chopper saying that
he's ready to.
I don't think we actually heard Chopper
say anything in the previous trailers
My guess is that most of the footage
is from those first couple of episodes
like before the first half of the season.
Usually they do that.
Like sometimes I'll show you footage
from like really late in the episodes,
but usually the promos right before things
premiere
are just the first couple of episodes.
for those of you wanting longer episodes
from all these Disney Plus series
like the Marvel Disney Plus series,
the Star Wars Disney Plus series,
the first two episodes
that they're dropping together
are meant to be a little over
an hour and a half together.
my guess is that during those episodes
they'll reintroduce everybody to Ahsoka
and what she's been doing since the
last time we saw her on The Mandalorian
and catch things up with the ending
of Star Wars Rebels in that time Jump
two after Return of the Jedi.
sort of like an introduction
to the characters
for people who did not watch Star Wars
Rebels or the Clone Wars
or aren't familiar
with the Sophia's character.
Like just saw her
during The Mandalorian cameos
if you didn't watch all those animated
series, you don't absolutely
have to watch all the Star Wars Rebels
episodes to understand what's going on.
They'll give you like a quick tutorial
in these
first couple of episodes
about all the characters,
but it will enhance your enjoyment
just so that you understand
some of the relationships
between the characters.
there's a bunch of big stuff
happening in the next couple of weeks
and we'll get more Loki Season
2 trailer as well.
Ahsoka Episodes are happening,
so make sure to enable alerts
for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Ahsoka episodes will post every Wednesday
just like normal Disney Plus series.
The big reminder, though,
is that the Loki season
two episodes are moving to Friday,
which is what they used to be So
if you remember the way that Disney Plus
episodes used to work, they're actually
just going back to that for Loki.
there was a bunch of brand new fantastic
for movie news.
I'll do a video for that
as soon as possible.
everyone click here for my brand
new Loki Season two trailer video
and click here for all my Ahsoka
trailer videos and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!